in the indonesian capital thousands pack
pasar senen station hoping to get home
before it's too late
[Music]
i'm going today before they start
banning people from the 6th of may
i'm afraid i won't be able to get home
after that for the second time
indonesian authorities have banned the
traditional mass exodus of workers
before eid celebrations do not return to
your hometown
do not go on holiday in your hometown
these travelers are trying to leave
jakarta before the band takes effect
later this week only business travelers
and those with special exemptions will
be permitted to travel
under the restrictions under normal
circumstances
more than 20 million indonesians would
travel back to their hometowns
for eid festivities but the travel
restrictions will prevent
that sort of mass movement from
happening this year
regardless indonesian authorities say
they have to anticipate a rise
in covert 19 cases
[Music]
in the past 12 months major holidays
have coincided with an increase in cases
and occupancy rates in intensive care
units
we should learn from what happens last
year so that's why we
want to limit the people mobility
because of the potential imported case
from one
area to others in recent weeks scenes of
crowded markets have led to concerns
that people are dropping their guard
during the holiday season health experts
warn the situation
is far from under control at least
indonesia already have
b117 we already have b
6 617 we already have also
the south africa variant
the decision to cancel travel isn't
popular with everyone
for many this eid will be a period of
financial hardship
some transport workers have had their
wages cut
the situation has had such a bad impact
on my family
my income now is only half of my
expenditure
for millions this time of year is
difficult for other reasons
for the second year housekeeper ernawati
will be away from her loved ones
during what is normally a family
celebration
i'm so sad thinking about my family back
home but i can't go
i'm alone and far away
but the government says it's putting
safety first
that people must be patient and stay put
to protect themselves and their families
jessica washington
al jazeera jakarta